PATRIOTS QUARTERBACK TO TAKE
THE FIRST SNAP THIS YEAR
COURTESY OF POINTS BED.
CAM NEWTON - 300 FAVORITE.
THAT MEANS YOU GOT A BET 300
TO WIN A HUNDRED MAC JONES
PLUS 350 JARRETT. STIDHAM,
900. I GOTTA FEELING A CHURCH
STEADMAN WOULD BE ON THE
ROSTER, HE MIGHT NOT BE RIGHT
BUT THAT THAT MAKES SENSE.
CAMS THE GUY I FEEL LIKE CAMS
THE GUY UNTIL HE'S INJURED OR
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY DO SOME
REVOLVING DOOR LIKE THEY DID
LAST YEAR WITH CAM NEWTON
INJURED STIDHAM BUT-BUT-BUT
CAMS. THE GUY TO AT LEAST
START THE SEASON I THINK SO A
HUNDRED PERCENT CAM IS THE
GUY, YOU KNOW, MAC JONES AS
MUCH AS HE
JENNIFER ALREADY COMING FROM
NICK SABAN SMART, AN AWESOME
POCKET PASSER AND ALL THE,
YOU KNOW, COMPARISONS TO
BRADY AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT. STILL, YOU KNOW, I NEW
ENGLAND'S, NOT THE TYPE, THEY
DON'T START. THERE'S LISTEN,
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO START A ROOKIE QUARTERBACK
THAT WE WON. I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT'S IN THEIR DNA. I
THINK THEY'RE FINE WOULD LIKE,
HEY, CAM NEWTON, HE'S GOT A
BASE OF THIS OFFENSE. WE GOT
SOME TALENT AROUND HIM THIS
YEAR AND THEY'RE GOING TO,
YOU KNOW, CONTINUE TO TEACH
MAC JONES, THIS OFFENSE,
WHICH WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IS
VERY COMPLICATED SO I TOTALLY
VISION OF BEING CAM NEWTON.
WHAT'S YOUR OVER-UNDER ON CAM
NEWTON STARTS THIS YEAR? I
THINK WE ASKED TOM CURREN
ABOUT THAT RIGHT AFTER MAC
JONES WAS. DRAFTED ON PFT P.
M. BUT, BUT WHAT YOUR
OVER/UNDER CAM NEWTON STARTS
VERSUS MAC. JONES STARTS. I'M
STARTS THE WHOLE YEAR, UNLESS
GIVES GETS HURT. I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE MAC
JONES THIS YEAR. I DON'T
THINK NEW ENGLAND CARES.
THEY'RE GOING TO SET HIM ON
THE BENCH AND LET HIM LEARN
FOOTBALL AND THEY GOT CAM
NEWTON, AND THEY'RE GOING TO
UM FROM WHAT THEY GOT OUT OF
HIM LAST YEAR AND THE WAY
THEY PLAYED AND THEY'LL SEE
WHERE IT GOES. YOU KNOW, I
GET I DON'T THINK LIKE NEW
ENGLAND'S IN ANY PRESSURE
HERE. THEY'RE GONNA CUT PIE
THIS OUT YOU KNOW. OKAY WAIT
CAM NEWTON PLAYED REALLY WELL.
OKAY. GREAT. WE'LL KEEP THEM
ANOTHER YEAR AND MAC JONES
SITS ON THE BENCH FOR ONE
MORE YEAR. I MEAN, I GET, I
THAT'S A REAL POSSIBILITY OF
CAM NEWTON PLAYS WELL AND I'M
EXPECTING CAM NEWTON TO PLAY.
WELL, ONE, THEIR TEAM'S GOING
HE'S GOING TO FALL INTO THAT
LITTLE, YOU KNOW, CRAP OLAF.
WARM HE DID LAST YEAR OF
THROWING THE FOOTBALL, WHERE
FELL APART FOR A FEW WEEKS.
WELL, I THINK COVID HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT. THIS
TIME HAS GONE BY IT'S BECOME
MORE AND MORE CLEAR, ONCE HE
THAT CASE OF COVID, HE DENIED
HAVING SOME BRAIN FOG, BUT IF
YOU HAVE BRAIN FOG, HOW AWARE
ARE YOU THAT YOU HAVE BRAIN
FOG, SO GO, YOU KNOW, GO
FIGURE OUT THAT CONUNDRUM. I
I HESITATE TO SAY THIS
TALK ABOUT HOW TEAMS ARE
GOING TO DO AND WE DON'T
FACTOR IN THE REALITY, THE
PROBABILITY, THE GUYS ARE
GOING TO GET INJURED. AND,
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU SAY CAM,
NEWTON'S GOING TO START ALL
17 GAMES, I SEE, THERE'S NO
WAY HE'S GOING TO START OFF
17 GAMES AND I FEEL BAD
SAYING THAT I HEAR YOU AT
SOME POINT. HE AT SOME POINT
HE'S GOING TO BE PHYSICALLY
UNABLE FOR WHATEVER REASON
AND ANKLE A SHOULDER. A
A THIGH A WING, WHATEVER IT I
IS, HE'S NOT GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE.
ABLE TO PLAY AND AND I HATE.
I HATE TO SAY THAT BUT YOU
KNOW THIS ISN'T YOUR TYPICAL
FRANCHISE. QUARTERBACK WAS
NOT SHOOTS UP AND PLAYS EVERY
GAME OF THE YEAR. AND I THINK,
FOR THAT REASON ALONE, I
DON'T BELIEVE HE'S GOING TO
PLAY THE WHOLE SEAT. NO, I
MEAN, LISTEN, I HEAR YOU. I
MEAN I DID SAY THAT YOU MIGHT
MAYBE YOU DIDN'T HEAR ME. I
JUST YEAH, UNLESS HE GETS
INJURED. I JUST, I THINK
IT'LL BE 17 BUT I HEAR YOU. I
DON'T WANT TO SAY, UNLESS HE
IS GETTING IN. WELL, I
DIDN'T GET INJURED LAST YEAR
YET ONLINE. IF HE DIDN'T, HE
DIDN'T, HE NEVER PLAYED EVERY
GAME OTHER THAN THE
A GAMES. SO I JUST THROW THAT
OUT THERE. YEAH. OKAY. THAT
MADE YOU PAUSE AND THINK FOR
A SECOND BUT I KNOW YOU'RE
RIGHT. IT'S A VERY REAL THING
FOR CAM NEWTON AS COMPARED TO
OTHER QUARTERBACKS BECAUSE
OF THE WAY HE'S PLAYED AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. SO I
KNOW THAT'S MIKE I MEAN
LISTEN IF YOU MADE ME BET
MONEY I WOULD BET YOU'RE
PROBABLY RIGHT ON THAT ONE.
YES. AND I DON'T LIKE SAYING
THAT EITHER BECAUSE WE DON'T
WISH THAT ON UPON CAM NEWTON
FOR SURE. WE'RE NOT, WE'RE
NOT WISHING IT ON EBAY. WE'RE
NOT DOING OUR JOBS. WE DON'T
FACTOR IT. AND I MEAN, THE
REALITY IS CAM NEWTON IS
ARGUABLY THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
PHYSICAL SPECIMEN I'VE EVER
WITNESSED IN FOOTBALL. HE IS
A GIANT AND HE IS WELL
PROPORTIONED AND HE IS
ATHLETIC AND HE IS JUST HE IS
HE IS A HUGE HUMAN BEING AND
THIS GETS BACK TO THE DEBATES
THAT THAT RAGED. REMEMBER THE
2016 SEASON, THE OPENER, THE
REMATCH OF THE PANTHERS
BRONCOS. GAME FROM SUPER BOWL
50 TO START.
SEASON CAM NEWTON, GOT THE
CRAP BEAT OUT OF HIM IN THAT
GAME AND THEY DON'T THROW THE
FLAG AND THEY DON'T THROW THE
FLAG, THEY DON'T THROW THE
FLAG BECAUSE THEY SEE THIS
GIANT AGREED. THERE ARE THE
LILLIPUTIANS, BOUNCING OFF OF
HIM AND YOU THINKING HE'S
FINE AND HE'S THINKING I'M
FINE AND THE COACHING STAFF.
THAT'S CALLING THE RUNNING
PLAYS - YEAH, HE'S FINE AND
CALLING THE RUNNING PLAYS -
YEAH HE'S FINE AND THEN
SOMETHING BREAKS. AND AND
THAT'S THE I THINK THAT'S THE
I THINK THAT'S THE THE
THAT THE PATRIOTS HAVE, MAYBE
PROPERLY RECONCILE, EVEN
THOUGH YOU LOOK AT THIS GUY
AND SAY MY GOD, HE'S
INDESTRUCTIBLE. NO, WE'VE
SEEN ENOUGH OVER THE LAST 10
YEARS TO KNOW THAT HE IS
DESTRUCTIBLE AND YOU HAVE TO
FACTOR THAT INTO HOW YOU USE.
YEAH, AND YOU KNOW, I THINK
THEY DID FACTOR THAT TO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING TO THEIR WAS
GAMES WHERE YOU THOUGHT, HEY,
GOING TO RUN HIM A LOT TODAY.
I EXPECT THAT YOU DIDN'T
REALLY SEE HIM RUN MUCH AT
ALL OR NO QUARTERBACK DESIGN
RUNS. I THINK THEY WERE WARY
OF TRYING TO KEEP HIS BODY
HEALTHY AND AND STILL ABLE TO,
YOU KNOW,
PERFORM AT A HIGH LEVEL, BUT
IT'S A DIFFERENT ANIMAL. WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CAM
NEWTON AT THE QUARTERBACK
POSITION, ESPECIALLY AT THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION
ESPECIALLY AT THE AGE OF 32
AND I'M ROOTING FOR HIM, I
REALLY AM. HE'S BEEN DEALING
WITH A LOT AND OF COURSE, THE
HATERS ARE ALL OVER THE OVER
THEM BECAUSE THE LAST YEAR
AND THE FACT OF THE WAY IT
LOOKED WITH THE PATRIOTS AND
OF COURSE, HE WENT THROUGH
SUCH A BAD STRETCH THROWING
THE FOOTBALL. SO HE'S GOT A
LOT OF A LOT OF CRITICS. HE'S
GOT TO KIND OF WIPE OFF HIS
SHOULDERS HERE THIS YEAR. I
HAVEN'T TOLD THIS STORY IN A
WHILE AND IN THE EVENT
THERE'S SOMEONE OUT THERE
HASN'T HEARD IT BEFORE AND
THERE'S PROBABLY PLENTY OF
FIRST, CAM NEWTON EXPERIENCE
WAS WALKING DOWN SIXTH AVENUE
TOWARD RADIO, CITY, MUSIC
HALL, 2011 DRAFT, AND THEY
WERE WALKING GUYS ON THE RED
CARPET AND I SAW CAM NEWTON
AND I THOUGHT, OH, THEY HAD
THEIR ON AN ELEVATED PLATFORM
AS THEY WALK ON THIS RED
CARPET, AS I GOT CLOSER AND
CLOSER, I REALIZED THERE WAS
NO ELEVATED MAP
BY IS A GIANT AND HE WAS
SCARED. HE JUST HEAD AND
SHOULDERS ABOVE EVERYONE, AND
THAT'S HOW HE IS. IF YOU'RE
THE SIDELINES OF A FOOTBALL
FIELD, HE'S HEAD AND
SHOULDERS ABOVE
ALL RIGHT, THE THE
HERE'S SOMETHING THIS LAST
YEAR. AS THE SEASON
APPROACHED, WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE OFFENSE WAS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE. AND MY BEST
INFORMATION WAS THAT JOSH
MCDANIELS WAS GOING TO TAKE
THE OFFENSE, HE HAD DEVISED
FOR TIM TEBOW IN DENVER, BUT
NEVER GOT TO USE AND USE THAT
WITH CAM NEWTON IN NEW
ENGLAND AND A LOT OF THAT
CAME TO FRUITION. HOW DO YOU
CREATE A PLAYBOOK THAT HAS CAM
NEWTON AND MAC JONES, BOTH
COACHED UP?
UP AND READY WITH PLAYS THAT
THE OTHER PLAYERS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO TO RUN BECAUSE
IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU NEED TO
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT PLAYBOOKS.
ONE FOR NEWTON AND ONE FOR
JOHN. YEAH NO THAT'S THAT'S
GOING TO BE A REAL ASPECT FOR
THEIR FOOTBALL TEAM. IT IS
YEAH THEY'RE GOING TO MAC
JONES IS GOING TO BE MORE OF
THE TRADITIONAL TOM, BRADY
TYPE OF STUFF. NOW YOU CAN
WORK ON ALL THE MOVEMENT
STUFF, RIGHT? THE FAKE, THE
SPEED SWEEPS AND ALL THAT,
KNOW AGAIN MAC JONES DID THAT
IN COLLEGE. HE WAS FAKING
DEVANTE SMITH. HERE, JALEN
WATTEAU FAKE JOE LET YOU
KNOW, SO YOU COULD STILL DO
THAT. THAT'S
TO THE FOOTBALL PART OF
FOOTBALL NOW, AND 2021. BUT
YES, AS FAR AS SOME OF THE
RUN GAME STUFF AND ALL OF
THAT, THERE'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT RULES FOR A CAM
NEWTON OFFENSE AS COMPARED TO
A MAC JONES. BUT NONETHELESS,
THE GAME IS NEVER JUST ABOUT.
HEY, THE FIRST AND SECOND
DOWN RUNS AND YOU KNOW,
THAT'S ALL THERE IS TO IT.
HEY, THEY'RE STILL GOING TO
HAVE A LOT OF DROP BACK
PASSES IN THE GAME PLANS.
MAYBE IT'S NOT AS YOU KNOW,
MAYBE THE PAST PLAYS THAT ARE
IS INTRICATE AND DEEP, AND
TAIL. LIKE, BRADY GOT TWO ON
PAGE 452 IN THE OFFENSE. YEAH
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR CAM NEWTON AND
MAC JONES BUT THAT'S OKAY. I
MEAN, I STILL THINK MAC JONES
IS GONNA GET PLENTY OF WORK
WITH THIRD DOWN, PASSING
PASSING. ALL OF THAT TO WHERE
IT'S STILL A DROP BACK PASS
OFFENSE. THAT WORKS FOR HIM.
JUST YES, WHEN HE COMES IN
THE GAME, THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE THAT RUNNING ELEMENT,
EVEN HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THAT THREAT AT ALL THE
PATRIOTS. SON, JOHNNY SMITH,
HUNTER HENRY, A COUPLE OF
VERY GOOD TIGHT ENDS. THEY
BORN TO NEW RECEIVERS, WHICH
OF THE NEW WEAPONS? DO YOU
THINK CAM NEWTON WILL HAVE
THE BEST CONNECTION WITH? I'M
GONNA GO WITH ONE OF THE
TIGHT ENDS AND JOHNNY SMITH I
THINK SO AND THEY'RE JUST I
WANT TO GO WITH ACTUALLY
EITHER ONE OF THEM NOW. I
REALLY LIKE AGUILAR AND BORN.
I THINK THEY'LL REALLY FIT.
YOU KNOW, CAM NEWTON, YOU
KNOW, BIG THE WAY THEY RUN
THE BALL AND THEN NEW ENGLAND
IS JUST THERE THERE, AN OLD
SCHOOL TEAM, IT GOES BACK TO
LIKE, YOU KNOW, THE GIANTS
AND PHIL SIMMS AND MARK
BAVARO AND THAT TYPE OF STUFF.
IF THEY KNOW HOW TO FEATURE A
TIGHT END, LET ALONE TIGHT
END, WHO WERE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
DUAL THREATS, GOOD AT RUNNING
AND GOOD AT PASSING. SO I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF
THEM, YOU KNOW, AND I'M GOING
TO AIR ON JONAH'S SMITH
BECAUSE I THINK HE'LL BE THE
GUY THAT ALSO GETS SOME OF
THOSE SHORT BOOTLEG PASSES
AND GETS TO RUN AFTER THE
CATCH. AND I THINK HE'LL JUST
GET A HAIR MORE PLAYING TIME,
HE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
TALENTED THAN HUNTER HENRY.
AND GUYS ARE IN FOXBOROUGH.
DESPITE THE NFLPA IS
RECOMMENDATION TO STAY AWAY
FROM
WORKOUTS THERE. THEY ARE
GETTING ACQUAINTED. OH, YEAH.
MY CREASE. IF HE S, PN
REPORTED YESTERDAY, MORE THAN
50 PLAYERS HAVE, YOU KNOW,
ISN'T THROUGH THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE OFFSEASON
PROGRAM? IS THIS GOING TO
CHANGE PEOPLE AND HOW THEY
DRAFT PLAYERS? SEE, THIS IS
WHERE NEW ENGLAND AND ALL
THEY'RE LIKE. OOH, YOU KNOW,
THIS GUY'S NOT AS GOOD AS
THIS GUY, BUT THIS GUY'S
PERSONALITY TESTS AND
EVERYTHING. FITS US MORE.
LET'S GO WITH THEM. WHERE
SOMETIMES WE GO. OH MAN, THEY
SHOULD HAVE TOOK THAT
TALENTED GUY. HERE'S THE
BENEFIT OF AIRING AND MORE ON.
WHAT THEY DO. LIKE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT A LOT, MIKE.
THEY GOT GUYS WHO ARE, YOU
KNOW ALL THAT. WELL WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO PRACTICE IN
THE PARKING LOT UP IN CANADA
TODAY. ALRIGHT COACH I'LL BE
THERE. I'LL SEE YOU. I MEAN
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE. SO
THESE GUYS ARE GOING TO BE
THEIR WORK AND WHY THE REST
OF THE LEAGUE IS YOU KNOW
SIPPING PINA COLADAS ON ZOOM
CALLS.
OR PIA. COLADAS IS THE CASE,
WHATEVER THEY CALL THEM
WONDER. I WONDER THOUGH. WILL
YOU DRINK THEM? EVERY FRIDAY?
YOU SHOULD KNOW BY. NOW I
WONDER AT WHAT POINT, BECAUSE
WHOLE BACK-AND-FORTH ON
OFFSEASON.
WORKOUTS AND YOU GOT TOM,
COMING OUT SAYING NEGOTIATE
DIRECTLY WITH YOUR COACHES,
YOU THINK BILL BELICHICK
GIVES A CRAP ABOUT ANY OF
THAT. AND AT WHAT POINT ARE
WE GOING TO HAVE GRIEVANCES
BELIEVED TO BE PUSHING THE
GUYS TOO HARD? YOU KNOW, IT'S
NEVER BEEN AN ISSUE THERE
HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT. SOME OF THESE
WORKOUTS ARE TOO INTENSE. I
JUST WONDER WHETHER THAT'S
THE NEXT FRONTIER IN THIS
FIGHT. COACHES ACTUALLY BEING
ON THE WRONG END OF
GRIEVANCES FILED. BY PLAYERS
WHO SAY THAT YOU'RE DOING TOO
MUCH TO CREATE THE IMPRESSION
WORKING IS TOO HARD AND I
DON'T THINK ANYONE'S EVER
GOING TO MUSTER THE NERVE TO
DO THAT TO BILL. BELICHICK
KNOW IF YOU GOT TO BE. THAT'S
A THAT'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE
VERY, VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE AYERS